Vong giây xuất hiện một dòng miệm cảm ơn,
thì kia giống miệm cảm ơn này,
xin ra một tưu chua người cảm ơn.
Giống miệm, ý xin là tưu chua.
Tà hợp rồi,
xuống quanh.
Giống miệm,
tí có tưu chua.
Vậy xuống quanh.
Vậy xuống miệm cảm ơn,
trái trang hồng lời này,
xuống miệm một tưu chua người.
Vậy là tưu chua người.
Ở,
dòng miệm cảm ơn.
Vậy xuống chua,
tưu chua người mà nó xin ra
chống lại người dân đây xin là nó.
Vậy là chống lại xin của tưu không?
Chống lại.
Vậy cái em biết,
tất cả tưu chua người mà nó của nó chung.
Vậy xuống,
để qua,
vậy qua là,
để tưu chung cảm ơn.
Sựng,
vậy tưu chua người,
chống lại,
vậy chống lại.
Chống lại,
đời.
Vậy có châu thế nào?
Chống lại,
vậy thằng lại,
đằng lại là tưu chung lại là tưu chung lại là tưu chung lại là tưu chung lại.
tưu chung lại là tưu chung tươi,
cảm ơn.
Vậy là em xuống tuyệt là tưu chung lại là tươi phải.
Vậy có thể chính theo châu quẩn vất ở với nhau.
Châu đứa bố.
Điều có em thái nơi châu quẩn vọng.
Vậy có thể là,
châu đứa bố.